yes some people can hear those crazy
fireworks alright look at everybody's
gonna play d4 now they're gonna start
picking on me well I'm not gonna go with
that anymore there yeah I'll just play
the Queen's game with the client and
hopefully this is better hopefully this
is better here all right get your pieces
out and get castled and get your pawn up
to c5 let's just strike at that right
away it's coming right at white isolated
pawn and take care I still and actually
I'm gonna take care next and just work
on isolated deep on isolate a queen pawn
position and get this Knight to d5
that's where he belongs
b6 Bishop d7 next bishop there should be
seven watch over this square right here
might be the move now I mean with this
bishops placement I could play here with
tempo another thing is that any Knight
b5 moves can be met with just not here
so this right here may be a move sooner
would have been better I wonder just
stopping my night from pivoting there so
more development Bishop here rope to c8
hit this guy
I get working against this isolated
queen pawn basically I will I'm
welcoming exchanges and now I think I
went upon is it worthwhile to do that
though mmm
could take here cuz like there's this a3
that hangs but later on like after a
bunch of exchanges on c3 there's this
Queen a form of which is hitting my
unprotected bishop and my pawn on a7 so
I think I've lose that back
hmmm let's see what is the plan what is
the plan here okay I'm considering
Knight takes Knight pawn takes if I take
here it's just that I don't know that
that's a good idea
cuz that the Queen gets here she's
hitting too many things she I think
she's too disruptive so what are my
alternatives maybe I can baby step this
something like a six and then I'm
threatening to actually win on a three
with those exchanges I want to try that
so my candidate moves I'm discounting
Knight takes Knight right now or you
know what maybe I should first take here
and then do this a3 and then it's
awkward to defend against that now no no
I'm gonna do this first so I went back
and forth there I was questioning the
move order I had a couple candidate
moves in mind and then I was thinking
should it be a and then B or B and then
a sometimes you find that you know the
two candidate moves you're looking to do
maybe if you switch the order if you're
thinking of doing one and then the other
flipping them might turn out to be
better
okay now the night is running away
scared so that night now this one is a
little bit more mobile you can jump in
here there's tension between these rooks
is it worthwhile to just pick up that
dark square Bishop this night can maybe
go here at some point
if I play here Bishop e5 then what do I
do now you're right here maybe I should
just do it and then think later let's
try that let's try that one maybe I
could like as soon as this Knight moves
I'm gonna have to do something but um
maybe like if the bishop does play here
I could come to d6 or something no not
quite sure f2 is a little bit sensitive
if the bishop goes elsewhere I don't
know if there is any tactics against
that point and I really don't have
enough really I don't have pieces in a
position really to do anything exciting
but it's a thought because it does
remove this a defender of eats free but
okay all right let's get rid of that
dark square Bishop no no an in-betweener
huh Oh
it's looking actually pretty good there
oh I think I need to take this rook
right now let's take this rook and then
do I win upon here I got to watch out
for we're after watch out for variations
where we enter opposite color Bishop
ending like I could go here and then win
this pawn I might work myself into a
little bit of a pin nothing nothing's
really coming about from giving a check
I'm also down on time again I'm
struggling here struggling I'm just
gonna go with something that's uh a bit
easier for me to figure out let me just
do this and then plant my Bishop right
here or maybe here is better yeah I
think I like this better
no I don't let's go here boxes out the
night I guess the Queen could play here
have to push that I might look on da
pawn g6 an ideal world given the time I
want to do g6 flight Square rook da King
g7 just kind of tucking him in maybe
even h5
should probably get that flight square
right now rook da coming up next and
maybe there's even pawn push at some
point let me go here is that rook gonna
be a pain it could really turn out to be
a pain here we're gonna see about that
is it the rook gonna come back over I'll
be happy to see that because it's one of
those strictly defensive moves so if my
opponent is tied up okay and they are
tied up so I'm gonna do this first maybe
there's this pawn push looking to maybe
get at my Bishop so I wanna i want to
strict these guys at the earliest point
let's do that this pawn is probably
gonna be hit soon know what
I could just get this pun right and then
defend it like this if I need more
support I'm just winning a pond here
rook and pawn endgame where I'm just up
a pond is that what we're gonna enter
I'm on f2 as well this Bishop is allowed
to stick around I'm getting worried that
my opponents listening to the stream
what's the story with that you know
you're not supposed to listen what is
going on
don't you dare listen let's go here
these are being recorded you know you
can listen back now while we're playing
oh man man how dare you how dare you do
that maybe you didn't know that's okay
maybe he didn't know it was against the
law to do that law all right well we're
gonna have to have a queen exchange or
another another guy another guy gets
that beat too pun my opponents asking me
you can't listen I can't listen the
stream well you could I'm not gonna stop
you
but probably shouldn't when you're
playing probably it's probably enough
all right let me give a checker ruski
and then my idea why should an idea is
to move faster than I did last game yeah
get moving quicker they are silly all
right let's get this pond right now all
right let's get this pond
I gotta get him the rook is kind of
trapped why might not move him fast
look out here they're gonna give checks
whoa that was scary
let's come over here I'm moving quickly
it's here tonight take that take that
it's guard everything I don't have any
time I have any time and this was not a
good spot to go with my rook that's not
a good move
okay oh I don't have any time where is
my time the riff moves again there's
trouble okay now it's working off are
working out here gonna have that gotta
go quick let's see this mouse let's go a
no accelerated Mouse no accelerated
Mouse
oh man the fireworks are going nuts here
good game did they know I just got lucky
here and won this game here woah grand
finale or what you don't know what I'm
talking about turn up your volume you
probably hear it then alright what is
the story
what is the story so we're entering
Queen Pond isolated Queen pond I've
suggested this before I think just um
why not III I I guess I just constantly
gravitate towards this a3 move because I
want to get to d5 with this guy for two
reasons it I want to control d5 but I
want I want this Bishop for when it does
play to b7 to have a clear view of the
d5 square and I think the coordination
becomes just so much easier for black if
allowed to make use of that be for
square my opponents saying sorry for
this initiative you have to apologize
that's that's fine you know if I know
there's probably the temptation just
like listen in but you could like after
the stream is killed it's there's a
videos tab and info tab so
be under the info stack there are the
info tab and you can track it down by
the little timestamp month day in the
year that's how it goes so and okay so
instead of castle I think look into that
eight three mil but I'm feeling pretty
comfortable right here pieces are just
kind of falling on the right squares and
when you have to do something like this
mmm that that right there is already
indication like there's probably
something wrong there's probably
something wrong prior so I look into a
three move if there's something I have
to or I could suggest it would be
relating to that particular move instead
of castles right here okay
good game let's close